hey this is presh talwalkar and you're
watching
mind your decisions
does anybody else watch marvel's agents
of shield
in season 5 episode 16
one character believes fate is on her
side and she cannot die
she wants to prove this with an
experiment
there are four cups filled with liquid
three of the cups contain water
the other cup has a liquid that looks
and smells like water but is actually a
fast-acting lethal poison
the character will select three of the
cups at random to drink
what is the probability she will live
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so i'm going to explain a few ways to
solve this problem
the first method is to consider the cup
not drink
after drinking three cups exactly one
cup remains
this cup is equally likely to be any of
the four cups so it has a one in four
chance of being poison
and this means there is 1 4 chance that
the character survives
another way to solve this problem is
direct calculation
there's a 3 in 4 chance of surviving the
first cup because 3 of the cups are
water and one of the cups is poison
conditional and surviving the first cup
there is a two-thirds chance of
surviving the second cup as there would
be two cups of water remaining out of
three cups in total
now conditional and surviving the first
two cups there is a one in two chance of
surviving the third cup as there would
be one water cup remaining out of two
to get the chance of surviving the
person has to drink all three cups that
are water so he multiplied these odds
the probability of surviving is
three-fourths times two-thirds times
one-half which equals one-fourth
finally we can solve this using
combinations
there are four choose three which equals
four ways to choose the three cups to
drink
there's only three choose three or one
way to choose the three water cups you
have to pick all three water cups
thus there is a one in four chance to
pick only the water cups and live
so notice this one in four chance of
surviving is pretty large it's like
someone guessing two coin flips in a row
and then claiming the test proves
clairvoyance
i'm thrilled to see this kind of math
problem in a popular tv show and i hope
this trend continues should any tv
writers ever want some good ideas
perhaps even more challenging problems
they are welcome to consult any of the
400 plus videos on my youtube channel i
do get email requests of this sort and i
would be happy to help
did you figure it out
thanks for watching these math videos
which can be watched for free on youtube
inspire and build confidence for people
around the world and they have over a
hundred million views please subscribe
for free to get the newest videos and
email me a puzzle or math topic presh
mindyourdecisions.com if you so choose
you can check out my merchandise which
is listed at teespring you can check out
my books which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon for exclusive rewards thanks for
watching and thanks for your support